[Music]
yeah my name is horgash beagle i'm a
plant
biotechnology scientist at the follow
for ime
is a largest non-profit research
organization in germany
and we address more or less all
different
types of science from engineering to
life science and our institute is
specialized on life science and with a
strong focus on flood
plant biotechnology and i'm happy that i
have the opportunity to present
some of our work and molecular farming
in general
in the context of the science week
[Music]
yeah i think the part that plant
molecular biology or
especially plant molecular farming place
in the context of the
big science puzzle is its contribution
to
a recombinant protein expression
expression
of proteins that we can use for
different purposes
and especially where other technologies
that have been developed
to do this job are not efficient enough
not fast enough
or not cheap enough to fulfill or to
solve the problems
that we want to address by this there
are many of these problems
especially in health and also in
world nutrition
uh we are in a critical point in
different respects
one critical point of course is the
the timelines that we usually need to
develop
safe vaccines and
this probably cannot be shortcuted much
better than we tried now and we are also
at a critical point when it comes to
the production of protein-based
therapeutics or diagnostics because here
we have
we have in general we have capacity
problems
with biotechnology production facilities
and also with the supply of media and
consumables and this is all
emphasized during the crisis when in
certain countries production capacities
get lower and the general trend
between producing countries and
the scientific countries that produce
reagents is probably not
not completely in place
[Music]
the duty of the science is to provide
solutions for
therapy solutions for immunization
and also for a detection of the pathogen
to
to allow better control and for as
as much as you need vaccines that are
probably recommend protein based
you need diagnostic reagents that will
be recommended proteins
representing important parts of the
virus
to develop rapid diagnostic assays for
example to monitor
antibody responses in patients and this
is
a scenario where we have to act very
quickly
and we have to and we need capacities
that are not used otherwise
to develop and produce these molecules
and
this is a critical point because such a
pandemic
with needs on both sides vaccines of
reagents has not been
addressed in the in the industrialized
time for us
as scientists and so it is very
important to look
and and and engage all technologies
like we can think of to solve the
problems we have with
recombinant protein production and asset
development and i think that
molecular farming will be able to make a
big contribution if not to this
crisis at least to the next pandemic
when we have learned
what we missed this time
[Music]
molecular farming is a set of
technologies that we can use
to make plants produce recombinant
proteins
that we need for medical or industrial
applications
molecular farming is an interesting
technology
because it helps us to rapidly produce
important vaccines and therapeutics
for for the future challenges in
global health
[Music]
given you use the right system and you
have two capacities to use it
we can produce sufficient amount of
diagnostic reagents
for for example pandemic monitoring
within two to three weeks
[Music]
the high speed of plant molecular
farming setups
results from the possibility to use
transient transfection technologies also
at a larger scale
so mammalian cells are also capable to
be applied in transient expression
systems
but only at very small scales where we
talk about
culture volumes of one liter or so
whereas in plant
systems where you use aggro infiltration
you can use
50 or 100 kilograms of blood material
and quickly
use them for production by transient
transfection and
the scale is the biggest advantage in
terms of
fast transient systems in molecular
[Music]
farming
we have a process that can be used to
produce
weekly about 1 million doses of
diagnostic reagent that could be used in
antibody assays that measure the
antibody tita corona virus specific
antibody
titan patients so that was the process
that we
established over three months very early
when corona started
so we should should very much learn from
the current situation
that we have to decentralize
supply of reagents and recombinant
proteins in a way that
we are not affected by pandemics just
because
just certain countries produce reagents
or consumables and other countries do
the science
but we should look for a better
distribution of capacities
and and and supply
i think the the biggest contribution
molecular farming can make to
this and more more importantly to coming
pandemics
is that molecular farming with its
flexible
fast and robust production systems for
recombinant proteins
we'll be able to quickly deliver
urgently needed
reagents and therapeutics given we take
the opportunity
now to learn that we have to work on
systems that are smaller and modular
and that can be transported to
countries as if you imagine the ebola
crisis which was really uh
more or less localized in sub-saharan
africa where you have
big problems with infrastructure and in
this case it would have been really good
to have
modular systems that can make quickly
make vaccines or
our diagnostic reagents probably on
ships or in containers
and the transient plant expression
technology
that we have currently is optimally
suited
to put them in smaller modules and
enable production
in a very simple and decentralized way
and the only problem we have to overcome
on the way to this is to
work on a faster and more efficient
methods to provide safe products
by adjusting the regulations we
we have for a good manufacturing
product production as a gmp compliant
procedures we use there
[Music]
at the moment we are in the phase of
molecular farming
or 3.0 because transient systems have
emerged
where we can much more quickly uh
generate proteins where we can make more
proteins because of the
replicant based things and it was it's
also a
question of selection of the right niche
if you don't take the right niche
to establish the technology far enough
to convince industry to use it also for
as a real alternative to mammalian cells
for example you have to make a critical
mass a critical mass of applications
so you have to enough processes are
established by the regulatory
authorities
and enough uh enough uh um
infrastructures that work on this so
that the industry can rely on
on infrastructure they can rent or use
for production once they have
established a process
and one of the niches that molecular
farming needs more or less even if it's
a
set effect is a pandemic where
the normal systems and the normal
capacities somehow
touch their limits regarding time or
capacity constraints
and this is when it gets more obvious
that we have to invest
maybe in alternative systems like plants
because we may need them
in in situations where we cannot
uh clarify or manage everything with the
existing capacities in the existing
systems
and molecular farming is an expression
technology
that has not at all reached its total
potential
in the context of recombinant protein
expression that is what i believe
because also of the big varieties we
have there
and i think we can be pretty confident
that in the future we will see more
molecular farming products
[Music]
the turtle to overcome is the the
the touching or the surpassing of a
critical mass
because the critical mass we cannot move
further with molecular farming
if we don't get products into the market
we have to show
that many products with different types
of plant systems can successfully enter
the market and go through the regulatory
process
and the pandemic now is a chance to put
the public emphasize
on these systems because they because
they are rapid
and good well scalable are a
a really serious alternative to the
other capacities
where we might have run into problems
that we have not foreseen
like sudden sudden lack of
supply for certain consumables or media
[Music]
components
yeah what we need is
entrepreneurs i would say that
have enough courage to to to
go from the from a development towards
the product
and to believe in the technology and it
would also
help a lot these entrepreneurs if we get
some
public funding to work on more
capacities more technologies and more
infrastructure
we have to really put a push on the
on the regulatory side so where that we
can establish safe procedures
that are must fudge faster than the
existing ones and that's especially
difficult for plant molecular farming
because we don't have a big record of
gmp production and gmp
process development so it will be more
difficult but it will be worth it
because once we have established it
it could could help to solve
pandemic problems decentralized very
fast
my plans for the berlin science week are
to take you
behind the scenes of molecular farming
and
take you into greenhouses into fighter
chambers
show you how we transform plants and
give you the opportunity to
interactively ask questions about the
technologies
to get a deeper and deeper insight and
understanding
and hopefully in the end
go home with a very good understanding
of molecular farming and its
contributions to global health and
probably also to a pandemic crisis like
the one we are
experiencing right now
[Music]
you